pellet et ça dès les jours qui ont suivi
donc est resté événement monsieur
pistorius a fait état de sa thèse de sa
version des faits et là on s'est employé
à essayer de la démolir et là c'est ce
qu'on va essayer de faire avec
évidemment un peu plus d'efforts et de
détails on va voir ici évidemment le
lieu des événements finalement cette
maison dans un quartier cossu de
pretoria et c'est à cet endroit donc là
l'aube du jour de la saint valentin le
14 février dernier que tous ces produits
la thèse monsieur piste heureux c'est
celui de la méprise c'est à dire qu'il a
confondu à penser qu'il y avait 1 et rue
chez lui et s'en est pris à cet intrus
présumé qui en fait était comme on le
sait maintenant sa conjointe de l'époque
madame ce team cup donc voici un peu le
plan des lieux
c'est la chambre finalement la chambre
où se trouvait le couple au moment des
faits et dit qu'au départ ce qui est un
v6 qui s'élevait entre 2h et 3h du matin
pour aller chercher un ventilateur qui
se trouvait ici sur le balcon pour le
balcon peut le ramener à l'intérieur de
la delà de la demeure de l'appartement
en question
c'est à ce moment là dit il qu'il
entendu du bruit qui prenait la salle de
bains et c'est alors était alors
chercher un une arme une arme à feu qui
se trouvait sous son oreiller et s'est
ensuite dirigée sans ces prothèses donc
sur ses jambes vers la salle de bains
qui se trouvent ici la porte était close
verrouillé il a fait feu puisque il
entendait toujours ces bruits quatre à
quatre reprises 3 de ses coups de feu
ont été mortellement madame steam cam
qui s'y trouvait lui après après avoir
dégainé si on veut est revenu dans la
chambre à coucher c'est rendu qu'on dit
il qu'elle n'était pas là et a réalisé
en fait la méprise selon lui c'est à
dire que c'était elle et non l'intrus
dans la maison à ce moment là et ici les
s'est rendu à nouveau
salle de bain pour aller récupérer ce
qui était désormais le cadavre de mme
adams tin cup alors voilà pour si on
veut la suite des événements selon sa
thèse à lui ce en ce qui concerne les
prothèses en question au départ la
poursuite affirmé que non au contraire
il portait ses portes ces prothèses et
que ça veut cela faisait partie des
indices qui prouvait la préméditation
dans cette affaire-là
il semblerait selon certaines fuites
qu'effectivement mais pistorius n'avait
pas ces prothèses est-ce que cela va
l'aider dans la cause
on verra bien justement parlant de fuite
elles ont été nombreuses depuis le début
de ces délibérations et il y en a eu de
nombreuses dont la photo que je vais
vous montrer
je vous avertis c'est pas facile à voir
mais ça démontre à quel point on à la
difficulté du côté de la police et la
justice sud africaine à protéger les
éléments de preuve dans cette affaire là
c'est une partie de la scène de crime
qui avait été photographié par la police
s'est retrouvé dans les médias on va
aussi tenter
du côté de la poursuite de prouver de
mettre en lumière deux choses l'amour
des armes de monsieur pistorius voici
une partie de son arsenal y aurait fait
application pour là pour se procurer
toutes ces armes là au cours des
dernières années et l'autre élément sur
lequel on va on va se concentrer c'est
le caractère violent de monsieur
pistorius une centaine de témoins au
total vont être appelés à la barre dont
une ex copine qui va parler justement de
sa crainte de ses peurs de ses angoisses
au moment où elle était mais monsieur
pistes aux russes et elle se disait
menacé d' actes violents alors voilà
c'est madame steam kahn qu'on voit ici
aux côtés de monsieur pistes aux russes
dans des jours plus heureux et triste
ironie dans cette histoire elle aurait
eu 30 ans aujourd'hui même oui on n'est
pas si mal